- [Onlooker] Ooh.
- [Narrator] Seconds, that's all it takes
for a train to come off the tracks,
(train derailing)
like this one in Springfield, Ohio.
It's just one
of the around a dozen derailments
already reported in 2023,
according to the Association
of American Railroads.
Over 1,000 trains derail every year.
- Every single event that we
investigate is preventable.
- [Narrator] And while not all are severe,
derailments can happen in many ways.
Here are some of the
biggest reasons trains
go off the tracks and what can be done
to make the system safer.
Derailments are the most
common train accidents
in the US.
In 2022, 66% of accidents were classified
by the Federal Railroad
Administration as derailments.
That's across all 600
plus railroad companies
in the country, in both rail yards,
where most derailments happen,
and out on the main lines.
And track issues are one
of the biggest causes,
That can be a track that's too wide,
a broken rail or a warped track.
(train whistling)
Essentially, it's when.
- The track isn't ready for the train.
- [Narrator] Michael Hiller
is the deputy director
of the Railroad Investigation
Office at the NTSB.
He investigated this 2017
derailment in Graettinger, Iowa
where 20 cars of a Union
Pacific train derailed
at a bridge.
That year, 14% of derailments
caused by track issues
were because of some sort
of a broken track piece.
- The rail broke under
the middle of the train.
There's a portion of the
train that's on the other side
of the bridge and it's safe,
but then there's a pile
of cars and then behind,
there's still a bunch
of cars that haven't derailed.
- [Narrator] Some cars released ethanol,
causing the train to catch fire.
The NTSB found that the track
in the area of the derailment
was inadequately maintained.
- Every time it hit that zone,
it would just pound, pound
and pound that rail until
it eventually broke.
- [Narrator] In 2013, a
catastrophic derailment
in Bridgeport, Connecticut was also caused
by a broken track piece.
A Metro-North passenger train derailed
and collided with another
train, injuring 65 people.
In this incident, compromised joint bars
that connect two different types
of rail together were fractured.
- Once that joint bar is broken,
there's no longer a structure able
to support the safe movement of a train.
- [Narrator] In both cases,
the NTSB made recommendations
emphasizing track
maintenance and inspection
but it's ultimately up to the
railroads to implement them.
In response, Metro-North
updated its inspection protocol
and says it continues
to maintain a robust
track inspection program.
And Union Pacific says its inspection
and maintenance policies go
above and beyond requirements.
- As a track wears, it
does require inspection
and it does require maintenance,
and it's that inspection
that is really critical
to identify what types
of interventions are necessary
to keep it operating safe.
- [Narrator] Track isn't
the only thing that breaks.
Among the major freight railroads,
equipment failures were
the most common cause
of mainline derailments in 2022.
That was the case
in the February derailment
in East Palestine, Ohio.
The NTSB's preliminary report said
that an overheated wheel bearing
likely caused the Norfolk Southern train
to go off the tracks.
Sparks under a rail car could be seen
on surveillance cameras miles
before the train derailed.
38 cars derailed,
including 11 that were
carrying hazardous materials
and caught fire, damaging 12 more.
The incident rattled the
town, angering residents
who still worry about
damages to the community,
including fear of possible
water contamination.
- We all just want answers.
I think that's what everybody
here wants is just answers.
- [Narrator] The Environmental
Protection Agency
has said local drinking water is safe.
It also ordered Norfolk
Southern to clean up the site.
The railroad also announced
new safety initiatives,
like adding more temperature sensors
to its tracks to alert a train's crew
of any trouble before it's too late.
Inspection and new sensors alone
can't prevent all derailments.
Many are caused by human errors.
That can mean going too fast,
miscommunication, or misaligned switches.
The NTSB has tried to
address human errors,
including pushing for safeguards,
like positive train control.
PTC is a system that helps to slow
and stop trains to prevent accidents,
like collisions and overspeed derailments.
- In my time, I've had at
least four investigations
where overspeeding in a curve resulted
in a derailment and a
very catastrophic outcome.
- [Narrator] In 2008, Congress mandated
that every major railroad
develop a PTC system
in the Rail Safety Improvement Act.
It took 12 years for all
of the railroads to fully implement PTC.
- Freight rail companies need
to stop fighting us every time
we try to do a regulation.
- [Narrator] Norfolk Southern
CEO said that the company
supports legislative efforts
to enhance rail safety.
In March, a bipartisan group of senators
proposed new legislation
that would tighten safety regulations
and increase fines, but
pushback is expected.
Industry Group AAR criticized
the proposed legislation,
saying some regulations,
like crew size requirements
wouldn't prevent future accidents.
(train rumbling)
Overall, derailments are
happening less frequently
than they were a decade ago.
That's thanks in part to
advances in rail safety,
including positive train control.
But for some railroads, the rate
of derailments has
increased in recent years
as they've moved more
freight over fewer miles.
Still compared to other
modes of transportation.
- [Michael Train travel is very safe.
If you compare highway
versus rail, the loss of life
is a lot greater on the
highway side versus rail.
- [Narrator] Hiller thinks there can be
more improvements when
it comes to rail safety.
- You have to have good maintenance.
You have to have good training.
You have to have good organizations
that really embrace safety
as part of its culture.
It's achievable, but it's
gonna take a lot of work.
(pensive music)
(train whooshing)